I'll sit in my office at work and we
were we were separated and I felt this
wave rising up and I didn't know what it
was I knew I didn't want to be there at
work anymore so I grabbed my keys my
Tarot just randomly for a couple miles
and just swung into this parking lot of
a school and it was empty and I jammed
on the brakes and I just lost it I was
screaming crying she had this feeling
inside of me like I was empty house is
empty
but it was more than that like I needed
something holy uh windows in the car
Gandalf fogged up so I got my breath I'm
you know wiped away the fog it wasn't in
the parking lot of school it was a
church I jumped out of the car ran
across the parking lot and the door was
open
place was empty I just went inside and
prayed for the the first time ever it
felt perfect
was in that empty church just praying I
didn't know any prayers just just
lifting my hands up and I could feel
God's presence just washing over me I
knew that's what I've been missing all
time finally when I came out into the
sunshine I didn't know what to do the
power that just makes me overwhelmed to
this day that was the foundation for our
healing and heading in the right
direction
[Music]
we unrelated to financial matters we had
a crisis in our marriage we were well on
two paths the divorce yeah God God
wasn't really a part of our of our
marriage and um you know we just I just
you know me I made selfish decisions and
I thought my life was supposed to go
sort of a different direction
I just couldn't see everything that was
perfect all around me
I'm Stephen Mullin this is my wife
Tricia we live in Cincinnati Ohio we've
got three kids three boys 15 12 and 9 I
head up the marketing group for a
transportation company and my wife is a
stay-at-home mom and a substitute
teacher when we got married we were 26
and 27 and you know financially we
didn't do a lot of preparation about how
we were gonna manage money how it was
gonna work in our marriage we actually
maintained separate accounts just cuz we
really didn't know any better we like to
have fun too
we went out a lot yeah that's true
I come from a very musical family and
when Stephen and I were in college I was
in a band with his housemate so I was
hanging out at their house a lot I
remember one day he was sitting there on
the couch playing guitar and I thought
this guy plays guitar so music has been
a big part of our our marriage too early
on in our marriage we lived in a an
apartment up from a little city square
and we used to literally walk down with
an acoustic guitar and play and that was
our that was our fun that was our date
night and when it was done we walked
back up the hill to our apartment and it
was just a big part of our life we had
fun
[Music]
the divorce papers were written they it
was done it was a done deal we just
hadn't filed yet yeah we weren't
speaking at the time at all we were
separated and I vowed not to speak to
him again because I money left he made a
choice and I was going to honor that
choice and it was then that he told me
he had an experience and I didn't truly
believe it at first and I hate to be
that cynical but I thought that he was
lying to get me back and I said well if
it happened let's you prove it
and I hated to be that cynical but it
was you know boundary that I needed to
keep and he came back a couple months
later with a five-page plan of how he
was going to change I mean it was
amazing and he's always been one that's
very organized and thought and we sat
there in a coffee shop for I think like
five and a half hours it was then that I
start
the plan was an opportunity to rebuild
that trust and it was a slow process and
I understood that we said it's her terms
and her timeline and I was just grateful
for the opportunity
[Music]
well when God crashed into my life and
brought us
I wouldn't say back together but on the
path to healing that led us to a church
we had at that point just accepted that
we were gonna go where God led us when
we got into that church we just started
getting growing relationships with some
really great people and in the bulletin
one day they were offering the Financial
Peace University you know that's not a
huge crisis point in our marriage but
we've had no plan we've never really
been together on money or managing money
or having a plan to go somewhere and we
just decided we were gonna be all in
we're gonna listen to what they were
gonna say we just went in with our eyes
wide open
[Music]
I think I think a lot of times in
marriage and in money you try and solve
the symptom and what we found is you
have to look deeper than that you know
certainly they were day-to-day things
that were not right but the root issue
was more than that it was foundational
it was the fact that God wasn't part of
our marriage we weren't building upon
that our priorities were not in order I
think financially the same thing can be
true you can get in fights over this
particular financial decision that
somebody made but but the root issue is
that you haven't really discussed where
you're trying to go as a family here's
what money means to us and here's how
we're gonna manage it and and here's why
and here's why yeah so the why is huge
right we were on fire with our why
because when we got back together we
knew that we could do anything we just
had to sit down and say all right well
how do we do that and as a family we
need to work together to get there and
being debt-free was a huge part of that
but we were looking to change our family
tree and put our family back together
you know once we got to a foundation
it's almost as if we looked at our
marriage and said how do we how do we
restart this how do we do this entirely
better than we had before how do we not
go back into the old ways just being
free to trust God and marriage and in
the day-to-day and in the bigger stuff
and in the financial piece that's a huge
change in the way I looked at life once
we figured our door why it makes
everything else more manageable you can
you can get to the day-to-day decisions
and work through the disagreements we
don't wish the hard time that we went
through on anybody but
we're in a complete agreement that
something like that had to happen for us
to really get the foundation that we
needed and it goes back to in that
moment in the parking lot when I said I
felt helpless
in a big way that meant turning over
control to God financially and in our
marriage and just trusting that he's
taken us to all the right places and you
just have to trust in that you know the
paid for house was really really cool
but the rest your stories better we went
down to our dairy screamed not really
expecting to share a lot of our detailed
story we're hoping that what we're
talking about can help somebody else you
know God tells stories of his greatness
through sometimes messy situations right
if you look at the Bible there's quite a
few just being able to have that
experience kind of brought kind of a
closure and a celebration to the whole
situation that we had
I think it's similar to what you do to
celebrate victories along the way
however you celebrate them whether it's
a dinner out or cake at home or you know
7:00 the kids involved in a countdown to
paying something off those milestones
are really important and doing that
debt-free scream to be at the end of
that journey like I said you kind of
mark that and then you move forward and
take your family where you want to go
right it's all it's a it's a step along
the way but God had truly taken us from
a point of despair to hope when we took
the class we found that we were looking
together along a path rather than just
at each other we were working together
you know a hand in hand and the kids
were able to see us talk about money and
understand how money kind of flows into
and through a family life and it it just
became an open conversation through that
they've really gotten to see just how
money kind of factors into your life and
your marriage and your family and your
and even your ability to help people and
be charitable and to be giving you're
moving away from something but then you
need to move towards something the
healing path we were on turned us around
and the financial piece led us manage
and actually move towards something
towards a just a destination for our
family there's a whole family restored
here and kept intact with this marriage
and a future and a legacy that has
changed
so our divorce papers were written and
five months later we found ourselves in
the seats of a Financial Peace
University glance
since then we've paid off two hundred
and forty six thousand dollars including
the house it's been a tough journey but
it's been a great one
[Music]
[Music]